welcome members
to the extraordinary cabinet meeting on
the 8th of june 2021
uh just run through the procedures fire
alarm procedures
if the fire alarm is activated vacuum
vacate the offices via the stairs please
do not use the lifts
assemble in hawley square on the green
officers will assist you and advise when
it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber
please switch off or turn to silent your
mobile phones and do not make or receive
calls whilst the meeting is in progress
please note this meeting is being live
stream for members of the public
the meeting will be also be recorded and
will
subsequently be broadcast on the
internet
filming does anyone intend to film the
meeting
no one is no one okay um
if any member of the public who objects
to the possibility of being filmed
they may wish to take this opportunity
to leave the meal meeting but as we
don't have any filming we'll move on
i would advise that if filming does take
place
anyone in attendance in the public area
may have their image captured
i urge anyone filming procedures to
avoid filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present
the following members have asked to
speak under council procedure rule 20.1
item 3 councillor ghana item 4
councillor austin councillor everett
item 5 councillor ghana
councillor yates councillor towning do
any other members wish to speak
councillor bailey
which items
apologies are there any apologies for
absence
no i think we have a full house
declarations of interest does anyone
have an interest to declare in the
business
in the items of business on the agenda
this evening
no so we move on to the
item agenda 3 margate town deal update
and next steps to introduce councillor
pugh
thank you leader this is a very exciting
time for margate and the town deal will
play a considerable part
in the regeneration of a significantly
important coastal town
in the southeast we are pleased to have
the opportunity to continue
on a journey of delivering its growth
aspirations for the town's residents
businesses and visitors which are
clearly set out in the margate town
investment plan
within the heads of terms we've been
provided we're in
excuse me we have been provided with an
in-principle allocation of up to 22.2
million pounds
against our ask of 29 million pounds in
the town deal investment plan
since receiving the heads of terms the
margate town deal board and the project
team have been working hard to identify
those projects that best meet the
priorities for the town's fund and
marketing
to ensure that we have a robust
programme of projects that will support
the vision for regeneration and leveling
up
sorry it's been long capital investment
in developing a creative land trust
refurbishing and redeveloping
redeveloping at the theater role
improvements to walpole bay the bathing
pool and access to the bay
including opportunity to test business
ideas relating to coastal well-being
and access to the sea will help to
create jobs skills and employment
pathways
investment in the oval bandstand and
skate park will provide opportunities to
engage the communities living in
the most deprived areas of margate and
will aim to encourage
engage and support young people in the
town improving the public realm
enabling people to move around margate
and cliftonville more easily
will help spread the growth
opportunities and improve the look of
the town centre
and coastal strip in cliftonville
investment in some of them of margate's
heritage assets
will support the future of these
much-loved buildings and will enable
them to grow and take advantage of the
town's economic growth
we've been asked to note this update
report on the margate town deal
as the programme moves into the second
stage of its development putting the
business cases together
that will provide a road map for
delivery i look forward to hearing
more detail about the delivery and the
progress of the margate town deal board
and the project team over the coming
months
thank you councillor pugh speakers under
20.1
councillor ghana
thank you thank you leader we believe it
is paramount that the projects
associated
with the margate town deal have
progressed with full transparency
in relation to how decisions are made
and how the money is spent
key to this is in we believe is the
involvement of the people's panel
which i understand is to grow in size
from 20
to 50 people representing the various
sections of the local community
who will be benefiting from these
projects the panel could
and should play a key role in overseeing
the projects and ensuring full community
engagement
it is important that all aspects of the
project especially all financial
transactions
should be made public and explained
government guidance for town funds sets
out the standards regarding transparency
of meetings and papers
with the default position being that all
are open to the public
and i hope we will be committing to this
level of transparency
including for all funding transactions
all the data will be there
it just needs to be made available
publicly
thank you
[Music]
thank you councillor ghana chief exec
would you like to respond
yes of course chairman uh
chair sorry chair um yes
absolutely uh i can confirm that
obviously these are matters for the
margate town deal board
and we are already sharing a lot of
information there's a specific website
allocated uh on behalf of the board
where you will find a range of
information in relation to the margate
town deal board
including the uh as you quite rightly
pointed out
the um people's panel who are having a
very active role
in respect of this project uh louise i
don't know if there's anything else you
would like to add to that
yep so as you said we are looking to
increase the number of people on the
people's panel we've had some people
drop
off because uh other um commitments and
we're trying to make it a very
representative panel
to make sure that the projects that are
already identified in the investment
plan so we're not looking at developing
new projects
are representative of those people
businesses and visitors in margate and
what we're looking at to deliver
in terms of the financial transparency
we're currently working with central
government
on their monitoring and evaluation
requirements which includes monitoring
on
all elements of financial at an
investment plan level
and at a specific project level so
that's something that um
we've been talking to finance about how
we can represent that and show that
because at the moment it's a series of
indicators and spreadsheets
but to make sure that people understand
the way in which that money is being
spent
and the way the projects are being
delivered
thank you luis um would you like to move
thank you leader i move the motion that
we
consider and note this update report
do i have a secondary sure
do we all agree
okay we can move on now to item four
landscape
future initiative and leveling up fund i
will introduce this
we welcome the opportunity to provide to
thanet by central government as priority
one area for the recently announced
levelling up fund
the priority of the leveling up fund is
to focus resources
on areas of deprivation in education and
skills employment
productivity and to those areas that
need support for economic growth and
recovery
following the impact of the pandemic
then it has some significant hot spots
in the district where leveling up
is set out in by central government is
needed
two-thirds of most deprived lower super
output areas are in margate
and an accessible offer from the
ministry of
ministry of house communities and local
government for the town deal
will support the town's leveling up
requirement
the other third are in ramsgate and
significant government investment is
required to help drive regeneration and
job growth
the submission of a bid to the levelling
up fund will complement other
opportunities that are available to
thanet such as the successful
future high street fund bid margate's
town deal
offer of up to 22.2 million and the
heritage
heritage action zones this funding
opportunity will support the delivery of
regeneration projects in ramsgate
which will undoubtedly support the whole
district's economy
economic recovery and leveling up of its
communities
we know that the people of ramsgate want
job creation
opportunities for young people
enhancements of the raw harbour and
investment
to support the regeneration of the port
of ramscape
improvements to the public realm and
designing our opportunities for crime
regeneration of leisure and retail
spaces to encourage new businesses is
also important to them
the ramsgate leveling up bid will help
to do some of this
and the wider town investment plan for
ramsgate will include those things that
cannot be picked up by the bid
20 million in capital might sound a lot
but further work will needed to be done
by all stakeholders to benefit from this
investment from central government
there are a number of things that we
understand are required for the leveling
up fund
delivery will need to start within the
2021
financial year all delivery will be
required by march 2024
there is up to 20 million pounds in
investment
it is a capital fund and the government
is encouraging bids to
include local financial contributions
representing at least 10 percent of
total costs
although the funding contribution does
not form part of the gateway criteria
for the fund
there is an expectation a contribution
will be expected from private stake
sector stakeholders such as developers
if they stand to benefit from from a
specific project therefore there will be
no
expectation that the council will be
underwriting any financial contributions
referenced by a 10 percent
match in the government's narrative that
are required from the private sector
the recommendations are i would like to
propose the recommendation that a
leveling up bid
be submitted to the 18th of june
deadline
and amend the second recommendation to
delegate authority to the chief
executive
and the leader of the council for final
sign-off of the leveling up bid
cabinet would also add a recommendation
that the council will not make a
financial contribution in any form
within the 10
financial contribution encouraged in the
prospectus
thank you
those speaking under 20.1
councillor austin thank you leader
um i was privileged to be part of a
meeting uh
over lunchtime a an online meeting with
ramsgate town council and with
consultants and
um and colleagues here and i have to say
this is a really exciting
plan and um speaking as a ramsgate
counselor
we are fully behind it we'd love to see
other things included and and you
alluded leader to
to further work on the ramsgate future
uh projects because ramsgate town
council has a series of ideas
and various of the community groups the
ramsgate tunnels the granville theatre
and so on
have a variety of really well worked up
proposals and it would be great
to see these coming forward as well um
ramsgate really needs this the
statistics we were shown today were
shocking in terms of ramsgate's levels
of deprivation
we have youth unemployment at four times
the national average
we've had no growth in jobs in the last
10 years
in comparison with 10 percent growth in
kent and 5 percent growth across so
it really will make a difference this
focus on jobs and training
but we do need to see the other projects
happening as well the other thing i
wanted to say was that
people in ramsgate have responded really
well there's been 700
and odd responses in a very short period
of time
people are really keen to see this
happen but
going back to what counselor ghana said
earlier openness and transparency
as much information as possible about
what's going on about what's included in
the bid and what isn't once it's gone in
and as much information as possible
about how other projects that the
community has come up with may be funded
in the future and when
will be very very much appreciated thank
you
[Music]
yes i i just like to add that i also
obviously came in on this quite late
because of the change of administration
but we've found it very exciting and
i regard this as as a building the
foundations and the building block to to
build up but
we we need the private investment and
hopefully this will encourage the the
larger corporates to
to take a big interest in in thana and
yes
priority is the jobs especially for the
young
the young folk of thank you
councillor everett yeah thank you leader
and
and i welcome your enthusiasm for this
project obviously as i've been uh
key to bringing it forward in my
previous capacity as leader and cabinet
member
um i'm not going to reprise my my
reservations about
this kind of funding from central
government which cannot replace the the
lost revenue funding which this council
has experienced over the last 10 years
but you know i welcome the opportunity
for fanet to benefit from these funds
and obviously i'm
particularly keen that this this
particular bit should be directed
towards ramsgate
because we've all recognized that um
there is very significant deprivation in
margay and the council
and other agencies have worked hard to
address that but there is a feeling
in ramsgate that ramsgate misses out as
a consequence of that
so this time i think the council really
has to show its support for ramsgate and
put its weight behind ramsgate
and i understand um members who
represent other parts of
residence in other parts of planet
saying well why rams gate why not us
but the reality is we have to make a
coherent bid
we have to make a bid that addresses the
particular
criteria that the government have put
down and sometimes this is going to mean
that we can't make a bid
which is what the residents would
entirely like because these things are
shaped by government and we have to play
the game we have to
meet their criteria because we can have
a lovely bib which satisfies which has
something for everyone in it
but if we don't get the money then it's
just a waste of time
and i know when this when this bid was
launched one of the first things we did
was speak to the two conservative mps
who were both supportive obviously craig
mckinley was more interested in it than
roger gail which is fair enough
because it affects his constituency and
you know i haven't heard anything
tonight which suggests that
the new administration is going to
divert the focus of its efforts away
from ramsgate
and i welcome that because i think
people in ramsgate
would not understand if that happened uh
and there would be a risk really of
considerably alienating ramsgate from
this council if there was any diversion
i would say in terms of transparency i
think the time scales for this
are extremely challenging um this isn't
the same structure as the town's fund
bid
there isn't there can't be the same
level of transparency and i think it's
great we've had the engagement from
people
in ramsgate i'm really excited about
this opportunity
and i hope that you will take it forward
with the same enthusiasm that we would
and it will be a big win for everybody
in fanet not just people in ramsgate
thanks
yes thanks councillor everett um yes
it's um
important ramsgate is is an important
factor within
the fanuc community and the job of the
cabinet is to
look for opportunities for the whole of
thanet which obviously includes
um ramsgate and i'm sure that the
conservative
government will be offering up more
funds
as we go through so we can
attack those as and when they come up
with gusta and we will have the
knowledge obviously through putting
these together
so hand over to um chief exec if you'd
like to say a few words
thank you chair thank you leader i
i have to say um obviously officers and
i'm speaking on behalf of the director
of regeneration
and myself absolutely supportive of this
submission
i totally recommend recognize the
additional um
recommendations this evening around
actually the tdc
reassuring itself that we're not
contributing making any financial
contribution because obviously
that would not be appropriate but i
think
regardless of that this is a massive
opportunity for the district
and for ramsgate and it has got some
very exciting projects in it which are
entirely deliverable within the
the very short i have to say delivery
period of three years
but i welcome the general support from
members on this i think this is
absolutely the right thing to do
and i just also want to say thank you to
the director of regeneration who
has had to work really hard to get this
within the very short time scales thank
you
thank you i would like to move this
and do i have a seconder
councillor bayford
so we all in agreement cabinet
agreed okay charlie
so we move on to item five cost and
financing of disciplinary and grievance
matters to introduce councillor saunders
thank you leader retrospective cabinet
approval is required
for legal costs of approximately two
hundred and forty seven
thousand pounds incurred to date and
associated with ongoing disciplinary and
grievance proceedings
cabinet members are also asked to
approve resources to facilitate
the current plan for these proceedings
as future costs are estimated
in the region of four hundred and fifty
thousand to four hundred eighty six
thousand pounds
an urgent decision outside the budget
framework
the chair of overview and scrutiny has
been informed and has given consent
for the matter to be dealt with by
cabinet a report
will be brought to the next meeting of
the council on the 15th of july
cabinet members will see that there are
four recommendations within the report
before them the small
of this evening and can i just say that
the report
rightly sets out that it is the
responsibility
of the council's general purpose
committee and its investigations and
disciplinary
subcommittee to consider the substance
of these matters
as such this report only addresses the
necessary approval of budget required
for the costs
incurred to date and anticipated future
costs i would also ask the cabinet to
note
the concerns of the director of finance
in regards to affordability
i will go on to move the recommendations
but as a member of the gpc
and chairman of the idsc i will defer
all questions on this matter to officers
thank you
thank you councillor saunders um
speaking under 20.1
i have councillor ghana
thank you um i'd like to start by
welcoming the fact that this report has
been published and made available
for this evening's meeting so that
so the excuse me so that the residents
of planet are able to see how much these
ongoing disciplinary and grievance
matters have cost them so far
and how much more they are likely to
cost in the future
now is not necessarily the time to
discuss how we got here
but now is the time to consider how we
best minimize our financial exposure
going forward
we all know that we as a council cannot
afford to further
deplete our already much reduced
financial reserves
so we ought to be investigating all
options to reduce futures costs as much
as possible
the report states that while 22 000 of
costs so far
has been extended on external employment
tribunals
it is anticipated that in future these
tribunals may account for 408
000 i would assume that this is a
conservative
with a small c estimate and could also
increase significantly while i
understand as councillor saunders
mentioned that the gpc and the igsc are
responsible for the course
of the current grievance and
disciplinary matters
i would like to ask who is responsible
for making decisions
about the future direction that this
whole process is going to take
external to the tdc and ask them to
confirm that all
options are being active actively
considered
thank you
um on the basis that councillor saunders
is obviously chair idsc
um i think we need to refer that to um
estelle thank you
thank you leader thank you uh councillor
ghana so um
so i think your question was who is
responsible on the employment tribunals
for making decisions on their progress i
think
is that correct
okay so um
so any matters below the level of um
chief officer level any matters to do
with the employment would be the remit
of the
head of paid service as chief executive
so any decisions on any employment
tribunal
in respect of a more junior member of
staff
would sit with the chief executive if
the chief executive's unable to deal
with it for any reason she would
delegate it to an appropriate senior
senior officer any uh
employment tribunals to do with um
more senior officers obviously
can't be dealt with by
well ordinarily would be dealt with by
the head of paid service but if that's
not possible would be the remit of the
um gpc as the appropriate body to
give direction
thank you estelle um
next speaker under 20.1 councillor yates
you chair um it just has a bit of
background to support
um as um i was the cabinet for finance
during
uh the time where this report came out
so
i did have concerns about what these
legal costs were so
um i asked the question what are the
costs what they've been and what are
they forecast to be
and i'm glad that as a previous
council ghana has mentioned that around
the trump i'm glad that this is being
made public
i'm glad about the transparency um when
it comes to taxpayers money
um the 750k approximate
represents about four percent of one
year's general budget and this money
will be coming from the general budget
um and this because the money will be
coming our reserves
this does mean the future cost savings
or revenue generations will have to be
considered
um to recover our reserves so it's quite
a serious situation
um next i'd just like to highlight that
although this is we're discussing this
um i fully respect the idsc process
um and the on the ongoing work done by
the gpc so in no way is this
attempted to influence any of that but
this is purely we need to make
these numbers public um so i guess
my two questions are kind of is it
possible the idc can be provided with
regular commercial and financial updates
um on costs but cost to date
and forecast spend because i think
that's an important um
piece of information that the ideac will
need to consider and the gpc
um the second question is given that 408
000 pounds is a huge amount of money
to be spent on two employment employment
tribunals
our our alternative approach is being
considered by the gpc
to achieve best value for taxpayers
money thank you
thank you um estelle if you'd just like
to confirm that uh we will
on the basis that uh the financial
report has generated through the
through the channels that you are quite
willing to
continuously update the gpc and the idsc
on ongoing costs
yes absolutely i mean i think it's
important to consider that
have to be proper processes and we are
following the proper processes the gpc
and the idsc
absolutely and we're following the uh
processes for concern correctly
but there's no reason that they can't be
updated
uh with costs and it's appropriate for
them to know but obviously their
decision on
steps to take and think and ways to go
forward
you know obviously they have to balance
costs but also they have to for all
concerned
follow the proper processes um
but of course they have to take into
account it's a balance
and it and yes i think it would be
appropriate for them to be updated
regularly on the costs
position
thank you and i'd also like to reassure
that
every effort will be made to try and
mitigate the costs
for the employment tribunal
we are obviously only five days into
this
administration so we can have a full
look at
the whole situation and refer
we will come back on any
possibility of improving that situation
councillor towning you wish to speak
under 20.1
thank you leader well much of my
questions uh
have been answered by rob over there um
what i'd just like to understand is that
when did
we whoever was responsible uh
actually find out at what point did they
discover the actual
level of uh legal costs
and you know what was done about it i
mean we're hearing now that okay we
ought to update
uh the very good work that's being done
in looking into the investigation of
what uh disciplinary matters but surely
this is something that in order to
control something as big as this and the
cost
of lawyers and barristers is enormous
that this should be
part and parcel of any arrangement like
this so that
the committee doesn't get carried away
from the runaway costs and i would i
would endorse that that's what should be
done
thank you
thank you councillor tanning i think
you'll find that um your questions are
mostly covered in the report
that was offered up by um
chris blundell i don't know if you wish
to elaborate any more on that chris
or whether you feel that your
explanation in the report
sufficiently answers councillor
tanning's question
thank you chair and i agree the report
sets out the timeline associated with
the
development of costs
thank you so council as soon as you have
moved
i have a seconder
oh sorry i beg your pardon sorry i
didn't look at my notes
sorry counselor counselor bailey sorry
you wish to speak sorry
thank you yeah a lot of what i've wanted
to say that has actually been said but
just a quick couple of questions if i
may
um one will any of this expenditure
expenditure be recoverable through costs
awarded subject to any outcome of any
hearing
so the council can recoup some of this
public money
and secondly um i understand that it's
the remit of the id sc and gpc to
determine the level of legal support
they require
however are these costs monitored or has
the ceiling's been set or can they just
spend at infinity
thank you
estelle i think you need to ask about
the cost recoverable and also the
ceiling on um
expenditure thanks very much thanks very
much
councillor bailey um unfortunately if
we're talking about employment tribunal
claims
costs are generally not recover
recoverable so that's the uh unfortunate
situation
it's important to bear in mind in this
report that we have presented
sort of the worst case scenario so that
so yes
it is expensive what we've incurred so
far future costs are even more expensive
but they are the future
you know what could happen there could
be all sorts of things
before then so that's important to
remember in terms of the ceiling
uh we haven't we haven't imposed the
ceiling obviously beyond this report
this report sets out certain figures
you know we're not there yet we haven't
gone beyond that et cetera et cetera
and i think it's so we haven't set a
ceiling but i think the
point earlier about giving regular
reports on where we are with costs et
cetera et cetera will help
the appropriate people dealing with it
committees
to you know consider
how they deal with things and to have
those costs in mind so i hope that
answers your question
thank you estelle so sorry um
we asked you to move it again please
yes thank you um can i just say that
um i do welcome um recording
uh the legal costs both myself as chair
of ibsc
and the leader or as chair of um
general purpose committee um are
aware of the sort of costs we're talking
about
what i can't do as chairman as idsc is
allow my committee
to be influenced by cost
they need to follow due process it's a
very very complicated legal matter
and i wouldn't want to think that we
would we were taking shortcuts
that would come back and bite us at a
later date
because we've been influenced by cost
thank you
i move the recommendations thank you
thank you councillor saunders do i have
a seconder
are we all in agreements of the
recommendations
agreed okay
so thank you members i believe this
concludes the business for tonight's
meeting and i declare the meeting closed
at 7 30.
thank you very much and have a good
evening
you